oh [ __ ] back in the sand look it up next
hole yeah I don't know why we just don't
edit this to make it look like we're
amazing golfers we could but what's the
fun in that
this is tea time with me hastens trail I
got the machine a que la macchina Bert
la macchina Kreischer tea town whoa hey
sis thank you for coming out man
course we think these clubs pretty nice
this is crazy look at this look at this
bag take a look at this you got a custom
Club the whole set custom decided for
the club's
yep tailor-made and then they made these
wedges for me with my little secret time
wall I mean I'm you got some hangers on
there it's been a really cool and
exciting to be on the road with you man
I really appreciate you letting me tag
along it's been it's been great letting
me open up the body shots world tour
which was really cool you feel good
about it yeah body shots just blast
that's a probably the funnest I've ever
had to in the road in my entire life
first time you ever had a tour bus right
oh I'll never not have a tour bus I will
never do stand-up again about you have a
tour bus really that's it yeah it's the
greatest thing I've ever done it I enjoy
it
so [ __ ] much it's a saying it's like
it's like you have your all your [ __ ]
there and then flying is so easy you
just literally wake up grab a doughnut
sweatpants grab a backpack
and you're out I love it you're not
flying after every sin of you from
flying every few cities and you know me
at airports I drink a lot of airports
right cuz I don't like flying so it's
like I'm exponentially healthier because
I'm cutting out one time a day that I
would be getting drunk all I want is
people to watch this episode and go [ __ ]
he is so much better than Jay Larson oh
that was horrible I went to hot spin
this morning I'm gonna [ __ ] spent
nice it's a little right a little bit
forward not bad
over the left a little bit no that's
fine
you're right pass outs and you can chip
right in oh you're on the green and hit
the tree while at it Mickey Mantle genes
in the building la macchina by the way
that was a [ __ ] accident I was
supposed to be down here for sure oh
[ __ ] I'm back in the sand look it up
next hole
they just edit that one out guys please
thank you finesse that's it you gotta
get over just enough
my boss still [ __ ] rolling yeah I
don't know why we just don't edit this
to make it look like we're amazing
golfers we could but what's the fun in
that
god dammit beautiful ah no we can edit
that out right I like bernt's idea
[Music]
here's what we need a good Drive
straight ahead dude that's nice little
screamer Tasers we're exactly together
on all of our shots like dude getting
ready for a special is exhausting it
takes a little bit of the fun away from
it but when you're just writing material
and getting offstage and being like
everyone's in the green room right after
you get offstage you're like all right
all right hold on did you guys hear the
add the tag I added there and then
you're like wait wait you know what you
should do remember that joke you had
last year that you didn't end up using
you should plug that in there and you're
like it's the greatest it's the happiest
I've been ever doing stand-up today I'm
just I'm on the treadmill this hasn't
happened to so long on the I'm on the
hot spin bike and I'm writing jokes
about how big that black dudes dick is
and I'm just doing tags his dicks so big
he can't work out with that dick like
that he's got to put it in a bun I can't
jump rope he's gonna chip me like I'm
just writing jokes about it going like
oh yeah yeah we'll try those out this
weekend the most fun a comic has is
right after filming a special right it's
like it's like all your creative juices
are flowing
you've been harnessed for so long you do
the special and then all of a sudden
it's like everything's fair game no
you're fine
[Music]
and please hit a cameraman that would be
awesome
I'll be great you get that shot god damn
it did I just hit two trees I figure
right in front of the pen I hit two
trees a court path and it's the best
shot I've hit all day did you and your
dad have things that you guys bonded
over oh yeah oh yeah I'll tell you all
the things I'll show you all the things
that me and my dad say okay each other
when we play golf and it's almost like
jokes that we've been saying for now for
years probably 40 years my dad have been
saying the same go and playing play golf
all right person what's your favorite
one get up to the ball get up to the
ball first hole all right when you go to
tee off
hello ball this is silly [ __ ] it's an
old it's an old honeymooners joke
they're reading a book to learn how to
play ball
golfing he goes okay address the ball
[Laughter]
hello hello boy Pebble Beach [ __ ] no
matter that stay out of the hole
we're running they're running fast Bert
that's not bad that's not bad hey Zeus
some good roll there
good speed on a bird oh come on come on
come on come on
oh yeah that's a gimme yeah nice
[Music]
by the way I'm planning on getting a
hole-in-one oh okay
just so you know I called it whoo that's
right out of camera man that's gonna hit
them whoa
I think we might be both pretty far oh
jesus heads in another one let's do
another one close just a bit
okay close it [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] another one
hey Zeus this is how I live life
deciding how do you live life what's
your motto
what's your mo my motto in life is [ __ ]
the rules keep hitting balls until
someone tells you to stop like whoo I
don't care mine I didn't come out here
for a score I came out here for the one
beautiful shot that's why I love that
movie tin cup I just want to keep it I
don't give a [ __ ] about the score I want
that one memorable story that one story
were they gonna know [ __ ] that par
three Bert hit two but he hit the second
was a hole-in-one whereas the story I
want to hear that's what golf is that
one beautiful shot gets you to come back
yeah who gives a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
about the little the the small details
you want the big story hey Zeus there we
go that's me this way come out that's
why I come out is this that's what I'm
talking about is this look at this look
at this no dude I think you got me I
think you got me oh this is gonna be
good I don't know oh I don't know hey
Zeus yeah that's you that's you for sure
beautiful beautiful oh oh let me tell
you something I am I'm on a tear on
par-5 lately I've had two Eagles this
passed in 2019 on par pot okay
now the key is don't over swing Burt
you've got plenty of room more than
enough mass behind the ball oh you're
gonna get some speed on that we hit a
tree we're getting another one we're
hitting another one a zoo
we're definitely hitting a [ __ ]
another one this isn't evil here we go
nice and soft nice and soft Burt like
you're making love to a woman that isn't
your wife now let make let your wife
make love to your wife there we go there
we go hey Zeus that's it god damn it hit
a tree hazel no one more one more one
more right in the middle we got this hit
a tree a tree that's shot that's the
[ __ ] shot
hey Zeus shot of the day Jesus we're
looking at Eagle we'll find one of those
gonna balance we got Eagles on us or the
drivers 318 I'm just gonna say that a
couple more times to get it clean so
they make sure that this is drive was
318 everyone write that down 318 we got
it so those people back there are 318
yards away from us now we are at 318 to
be six 318 318 318 318 three one eight
three one eight all right hey Zeus
here's I'm gonna do I'm gonna do five
wood I don't know I got this little bad
[ __ ] that is a little screamer let's
get a little closer let's get some love
on this ball
there we go
hey Zeus it hey sis take a look at this
look at this is on the green hey ten
carpet that's in that house that's in
the house all right that's okay well
putt from remind coffee cup
okay can I tell you what I do what would
you do three iron screamer but it just
suspends a screamer that's a beautiful
shot that was a beautiful set of three
iron yeah three iron
well screamer you know a little 72%
swing I love it
what is one of your fondest memories and
stand up altogether I've won when the
girls ran up all stage of me at the
Irvine improv came out on stage one
night and they ran up and just ran them
during the Bahamas Georgia I said George
want to tell a joke said she grabbed
look like she goes why did the chicken
cross the road
I don't know why he's good why did the
chicken cross the road and every was I
don't know why it's cuz why did the
chicken cross the road I don't know why
and then I grabbed the mic from where I
go guys that's the only part of the
jokes he knows and then she did it again
why did the chicken cross road and it
killed and I go turns out she's an alt
comic gonna tell you my favorite oh no
no joke yeah yes since fifth grade okay
I think this is the funniest joke ever
alright say knock knock who's there is
the kill this is a makeable [ __ ]
eagle putt they're gonna think she the
haters are gonna say we did this in post
uh-huh nope he hit that yep this is real
how the [ __ ] did that stay out
that's okay one more here we go fur fur
eagle
that's a I was a speedy in it that's
look how [ __ ] fast this is running by
the way I don't even have a makeable
part button on my second one I got lip
[ __ ]
easy one more eagle putt so we can
string this evil together doesn't need
to be quite as far away ready
one more that's it [ __ ] it just here we
go here we go
shut the [ __ ] up shut up
Nathaniel zip zero not dammit we tried
that was a great Monday beautiful Drive
beautiful second shot and beautiful a
bit but for [ __ ] let me tell you
something I am I'm on a care on par-5
lately I've had two Eagles this past in
2019 on part Rock
[Music]
this isn't evil here we go damn
that's a screener inside
[Music]
there we go Azusa hey sis take a look at
this look at this on the green Hey
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice you have in slow motion for evil
beautiful beautiful beautiful
oh it's been a great day thanks for
doing this No thank you for coming out
horse
[Music]
you